الجزائر تتسلح باقوى الاسلحة
واعدائها في خطر. خصومها في
اوروبا قد يكونون في مرمى
اهدافها باسلحة استراتيجية فتاكة
مع اقوى مقاتلات الجو واسطول
بحري مرعب وقوة برية لا يشق لها
غبار ولها اسلحة مدمرة. وبين
الصواريخ الباليستية المخيفة
والغواصات التي الهلع على بعد
الاف الاميال. الجزائر تنضم
لنادي اقوى الدول في العالم.
بالقوة وليس بغيرها يكتب
الجزائريون مكانتهم على هذه
المعمورة. فكيف للجزائر ان تصل
الى هذه المكانة؟ وما هي الاسلحة
الاستراتيجية التي تمتلكها
الجزائر ولا تمتلكها اي دولة
عربية. اليكم القوة الحقيقية
للجزائر؟ بدأ التسلح يقلق الدول
الاوروبية. فهي ترى في اقتناء
سلاح الجو الجزائري طائرة من نوع
سبعة وخمسين الروسية ترديدا
مباشرا للتفوق الاوروبي وسوخوي
سبعة وخمسون طائرة من الجيل
الخامس تضاي الطائرة الامريكية
اف خمسة وثلاثين. لكن ليس ذلك
فحسب بل وقعت الجزائر العقود
الاولى التي تنص على اقتناء اربع
عشرة طائرة من كل صنف قتالي. تلك
الاصناف اذا? انها سوخوي اربعة
وثلاثون وسوخوي خمسة وثلاثون
وكلها طائرات ذات مهام متعددة.
قبل عامين ارتفعت واردات الجزائر
من الاسلحة بنسبة اربعة وستين
بالمائة. لتدخل ضمن قائمة الدول
الاكثر استيرادا للسلاح في
السنوات الخمس الماضية باحتلالها
المرتبة السادسة عالميا والثانية
افريقيا بعد مصر. نعم وهذا ليس
من عند انما هو تقرير لمعهد
ستوكهولم الدولي لابحاث السلام.
لم تعد الجزائر تثير قلق جيرانها
فقط بل اصبحت رائحة القلق تصل
لدول مثل فرنسا واسبانيا
وايطاليا حتى ان فرنسا لا تمتلك
اي مقاتلة تضاهي سبعة وخمسين.
فهي تصنع رافال وهي مقاتلة
متطورة ولكنها ادنى جودة وقوة من
نظيرتها الروسية. ويعد الاسطول
الجوي الحربي الاسباني متخلفا
بطائرات اف ثمانية عشر مقارنة مع
الجزائر وتبقى ايطاليا الوحيدة
التي تمتلك اف خمسة وثلاثين التي
تعد منافسة بالطائرة الروسية.
وهنا ما عدا تلك الدول الاوروبية
تشكل هاجسا للجزائريين. فمرحبا
باي مواجهة عسكرية معكم. حسنا.
ما رأيكم بمناورة تجريبية
لاسلحتنا امامكم او هكذا يقولها
الجزائريون. فيما تمتلك الجزائر
منظومة الدفاع الصاروخي الروسية
المتطورة اس اربعمائة وفي حالة
اندلاع حرب فهي قادرة على شن
هجمات ضد العديد من المقاتلات
الاوروبية. وزودت روسيا الجزائر
بصواريخ اسكندر اقوى الصواريخ
الباليستية في العالم القادرة
على ضرب موانئ جنوب اوروبا
وقواعدها بحسب موقع الامريكي.
الغرب من هذه الصواريخ ويحبس
انفاسه. وتعد الدولة الوحيدة في
البحر الابيض المتوسط رفقة
اسرائيل التي لديها القدرة على
توجيه صواريخ من قاع البحر
انطلاقا من غواصات حربية. هنا
يتابع الغربيون باندهاش وقلق هذا
التطور المهول للترسانة العسكرية
الجزائرية. الجزائر هي الدولة
الاكبر مساحة في افريقيا تشكل
مصر احتياطيا استراتيجيا عسكريا
للجانب الافريقي عموما والعربي
خصوصا وفي الجو الجزائري. تظهر
او ما يسمى بصياد الليل مروحية
روسية تستطيع الطيران في جميع
الاحوال الجوية حتى في الليل.
مصممة للعثور على دبابات العدو
والدروع وتدميرها تقدم الدعم
للمشاة بشكل مخيف. تثبت حقول
الالغام تعثر على او غيرها من
الاليات العائمة للعدو وتبيدها
تناور المقاتلات بمهارة. لننطلق
نحو اقوى الاسلحة التي تمتلكها
الجزائر وبامداد روسي حاز الجيش
الجزائري على اربعة انواع من
الاسلحة الخارقة وشديدة
الفعالية. وذلك نقلا عن مجلة.
غواصة الثقب الاسود. برشا فينكا
او الثقب الاسود. احدى اخطر
بالعالم تنثر الرعب باعماق
البحار. حصلت الجزائر على اثنتين
منها اطلقت عليهما اسمي اللوراس
واحد وثلاثين والهقار اثنين
وثلاثين بحسب موقع غواصة تعمل
بالديزل والكهرباء. لا تصدر
ضجيجا ولا تكتشفها الرادارات الا
بعد ان تصيب اهدافها متعددة
الاغراض بسرعة عشرين عقدة. قادرة
على السير بنفسها خمسة اربعين
يوما تحمل في بطنها طوربيد
الالغام واسلحة الصواريخ ومنظومة
الدفاع الجوي وقد اطلق عليها
الناتو باسم الثقب الاسود لانها
مخفية. منظومة كورنيت. هذه
المنظومة اضافت قوة كبيرة الى
قوة الجيش الجزائري. انها منظومة
الصواريخ كورنيت اي ام المضادة
للدبابات. فعاليتها دقيقة في
تدمير المدرعة والجوية والطائرات
بدون طيار. وفقا لخصائصها فان
منظومة كورنيت ليس لها مثيل في
العالم. تسمح كورنيت بالتعامل مع
جميع انواع الدبابات الحديثة
بنجاح. فيها حماية عالية من
التشويش. مهلا مهلا. فمنظومة
كورنيت تصلح لاطلاق النار من
المواقع غير المعدة ومن وضعيات
مختلفة. كالاستلقاء او على
الركبة او في الخندق استخدام
المنظومة في اي وقت من اليوم.
منظومة منظومة اسلحة فعالة
للغاية اثبتت فعاليتها في سوريا
هناك اعترضت صواريخ كروز وصواريخ
باليستية هي قادرة على اسقاط
طائرات في مدى يتراوح بين ثلاثة
الى خمسة واربعين كيلو مترا على
ارتفاع يبدأ من خمسة عشر مترا
حتى خمسة وعشرين كيلومتر. قدرة
حركية عالية. تستطيع العربة
المجنزرة التي تحملها السير
بسرعة سبعين الى ثمانين كيلو
مترا في الساعة. وهذا يعني ان
نظام بوك ام تو اي ينتقل من موقع
الى اخر على جناح السرعة. يقدر
نظام بوكين تو ايه على مواجهة
موجة حر تصل درجة حرارتها الى
خمسين درجة مئوية. فعن اي قدرات
نتحدث. راجمة قنابل. راجمة
القنابل اليدوية الروسية او مصاص
الدماء التي تكتسب شعبية متزايدة
في العالم. اي جندي مسلح بهذه
الراجمة قادر على تحويل مدرعة
بدرع يعادل ستمائة وخمسين مليمتر
من الفولاذ الخاص الى كومة من
الخردة المشتعلة يا لها من قوة
مرعبة. حتى اذا كانت الدبابة
محمية ديناميكية فان الرأس
الحربي سيتغلب عليها بسهولة.
ويمكن ان يهاجم هدفا على مسافة
نصف كيلو متر لتجعل هذه الراجمة
جنود الجيش الجزائري كمصاصي
الدماء مع رعب بشكل لا يصدق.
راجمة القنابل بامباير هي سلاح
للمحاربين الاقوياء جسديا.
فوزنها اكثر من اثني عشر كيلو
جرام. والجزائر لا تمتلك سلاحا
لا يستطيع استخدامه فهي تنفذ
مناورات بشكل مستمر مع الحليف
الروسي. سر قوة الجيش الجزائري
ونجاحه ليست في الاسلحة فقط بل
انه على اتم الاستعداد لتنفيذ اي
مهام داخل حدود البلاد اذا تطلب
الامر. لكن تبقى جميع الاسلحة في
الترسانة العسكرية الجزائرية في
كافة وانضمام مقاتلات روسية من
الجيل الخامس سبعة وخمسين. كفة
اخرى. صفقة سيتم تسليمها عام
الفين وخمسة وعشرين بعد اجراء
المزيد من التعديلات والتحسينات
على الطير. برأيكم انتم
متابعينا. اي الاسلحة الجزائرية
مرعبة اكثر.